hello and welcome i'm james murphy and
in this video i'm going to show you how
i used python and the youtube data api
to update all of my video descriptions
well
enough of my viewers have asked about
how to donate to my video production
efforts
and so i finally made a patreon so
basically i want to go through and add
my patreon link to all of my video
descriptions
okay the task is pretty straightforward
i just need to go through each of my
videos and add the patreon link
but then i thought why spend 15 or so
minutes updating everything manually
when i could spend 5 hours automating it
[Music]
[Applause]
alright let's automate it youtube does
have an api so
this at least stands a chance after
poking around for a while i found these
instructions on how to actually get
started
there were quite a few hoops to jump
through to get everything set up but
it was all free i made a google cloud
developer account
a new project for that account and
enable the youtube api for that project
unsurprisingly google is extremely
serious about protecting their api
and their user data since i'm going to
be updating my youtube video
descriptions i'm going to need access to
my own private user data
that means i'm going to need to use this
oauth 2.0 authentication method
i created my client secrets file from
the cloud developer console and
downloaded it
next i found the python client library
and looked at the examples for it on
github
it's written in python 2.6 so we'll have
to update it a little bit
it's surprisingly simple to install just
install the python client
and the authentication libraries i used
this example
myuploads.pi to figure out how to do all
the authentication stuff
of course i'm going to have to update
this for my own case
the first thing that i tried to get
working was just download data for a
single video
here's kind of the flow of any program
that's using the youtube api
first you figure out where your client
secrets file is
then you create an authenticated youtube
service and then use the service to do
whatever it is you want to do
let's take a look at how i create the
service this
is basically just my own wrapper around
google's authentication process
these scopes are basically the
permissions that you're asking for
either read only or
read write i'm only dealing with the
youtube data api version
3 so i'm just going to fix those
constants
so you just pass all that data to the
google code and then it builds it for
you
so back to downloading one video's data
the data api lists a bunch of different
resource types and the one that i'm
looking for
is videos list the api documentation is
not written specifically for python so
you sort of just have to look at the
python examples and then try to
translate it into what you want
i'm going to be using a specific video
id so i give it an id parameter
and then you also have to pass a part
parameter to tell you kind of what do
you want back from the call
it doesn't just give you all of the data
it has about a video you basically tell
it what you want
snippet contains basic information like
the title and description so we'll be
using that
back to the code we see that we use the
youtube object and tell it that we're
interested in the video api
and the list method then we give it our
video id
and tell it that we want the snippet
execute is what goes out and actually
makes the request
after executing the request we save
whatever we get back to a file
okay let's see what happens when we run
it the first thing that you notice is
that you have to actually authorize this
request manually
it gives you a link i need to go to the
link and authorize it i have to choose
the account that i'm interested in
and then again very serious about
security google is warning me that my
app is not a verified app
because i'm sure that this is me and not
a hacker i'll go ahead and continue
i have to agree to let my app have
access to my account in order to do this
again i know it's me so i go ahead and
allow it google gives me a code that i
then have to go and paste back into the
terminal
now i see this single line json file
that has appeared in my directory
for both of our benefits i'm going to
format the json so i can see what i'm
working with
as you can see the response that i got
back has a single item in it
that's of kind youtube video it has the
id of the video that i requested
and the channel that's me and we can see
the title and description are also here
you can also see information on the
thumbnails and the tags of the video
okay that worked this is a lot of good
information
well that was just for one video and i
already knew the video id
how do i download all of my videos
[Music]
i'm putting this in a new file the thing
that i had to figure out in order to get
all of my videos
was to realize that youtube stores your
entire uploads list as a playlist
so first i'll make a request to get the
id of my playlist
and then i'll go through and download
all the video snippets for that playlist
i'll use the channels list endpoint in
order to find out what my uploads video
playlist is
then i'll use the playlist items list
endpoint in order to find all the videos
on that playlist here you can see how i
query the channels list method
and then extract out the uploads
playlist from it
when i go to actually find the
information on the playlist items though
there's a slight problem the
documentation says that the maximum
number of results that you can return in
one query is 50.
but i have more than 50 videos when
there are more results available in
addition to the data you requested
the return query will return a next page
token to tell you how to get the next
page of the results
you then have to loop through and make a
new request over and over again until
you've gotten all of your pages
i made this paginated results function
in order to do this for me
here's the code for paginated results
but i basically just copied it from one
of the examples
for every page of results i dump it to a
json file
after running it and formatting it i get
similar json to the previous time except
this time there's more than one item
this time the object returned is a
playlist item so it's not the same as a
video
but it does still have the title and
description of each video
and it also has the actual video id that
i'm going to need to update the video
here's the code that i came up with to
update the description of a single video
i know i can get the video id from the
json that i just downloaded so i'll use
that and the new description as
parameters
after checking that the new description
contains only valid characters i make a
new request to download the data for the
current video id
i do this so that i can compare what i'm
about to replace the description with
with what was already there i download a
new copy of the description
so that i'm absolutely sure that i'm
using the most recent version of the
description to compare against
i wrote this function confirm diff to
show me the old
new and the difference between the two
of the two descriptions
again i'm doing this live on my real
video description so i don't want to
mess it up
i will print everything out and then ask
myself if this looks correct
once i confirm that the diff is correct
i then update the video description and
call the
videos update endpoint to actually
update the video description
live youtube responds with the updated
information
and as a final check i check that the
description has in fact been updated to
the new description
okay then here's the new file that i'm
using to basically call that function in
a loop
to change each description one after
another i load up the json data that i
saved from a few minutes ago and then
put it into a big list of videos
because i'm expecting that i might pause
and try again a few times
i'm putting this check in to make sure
that i'm only going to operate on videos
that don't already have the word
patreon in the description additionally
the first time i try this i'm just going
to do it on a single video that i've
chosen ahead of time
so that if the program goes rogue i'm
not going to lose
all of my descriptions once i'm
confident the program works i'll comment
this part out
here i load up the text that has the
patreon link in it that i'm going to
prepend to all of my descriptions
i make a dictionary mapping each video
id to its new description
after confirming again that i really do
want to do this i
make an authenticated service and loop
through all of my videos
updating the descriptions on each of
them
okay here's the video that i'm going to
test on first right now you can see that
there's nothing about patreon in the
description
59 videos total 58 of them don't have
anything about patreon in the
description
am i sure yes
and here we go here's the old
description
here's the new description has the
patreon link at the top
and here is the diff we can see that it
just added
those lines at the top and then nothing
else has changed
does this look correct yes let's do it
okay that finished instantly so let's go
check the video
all right the video is still alive the
description now contains the new links
it appears to be correct as far as i can
tell
i guess it just worked on the first try
honestly i wasn't totally sure that was
gonna happen
okay we tried once let's do it for real
let's update all of the video
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
descriptions
it looks like most of them went through
but it looks like on
one of the last ones i got an http error
400.
so i scrolled over and it's telling me
the metadata is invalid
so i don't see anything wrong with the
description itself
it seems just like any of the others it
looks like it succeeded
for all of the videos up until this one
so that's basically all of the videos
i think i'll just redownload the video
description data and
try again and it failed again
well i guess it wouldn't be a real
coding project if something totally
unexplainable didn't happen so i guess
i'll still consider it a success
[Applause]
[Music]
so was it worth it after all this took
me
hours and hours to do and updating it by
hand probably would have only taken 15
or 20 minutes
well yes i think this was absolutely
worth it and not just for educational
purposes
i'm now able to update the video
descriptions of all of my videos in an
instant
if tomorrow i want to add or remove a
link from the description
i can do that in no time in the future
i'll be able to keep all my video
descriptions up to date with all my
latest information with basically no
extra effort
so yeah i call that a huge win even
though i spent like five hours on it
today
if you like this video enough to watch
it all the way through you should
probably be subscribed so don't forget
and if you especially liked the video
please consider sharing with your
friends and
maybe even becoming one of my patrons on
patreon
again thanks for watching and see you
next time